we are lucky to have like a sewer who is
a graduating 5th year PhD student in the
department's of Stanford that's all it's
about
mystic regression I'd like to thank the
organizers for the invitation and for
putting together this wonderful workshop
I'm going to talk about a modern
maximum-likelihood theory for high
dimensional logistic regression and this
is based on joint works with my adviser
Emmanuel Candace in some prior work with
Fusion Chen so classical maximum
likelihood theory this is something most
of you in this room are very familiar
with and what you are probably in
particular very familiar with is looking
at this place like this and standard
software packages so this is a
particularly on a run of logistic
regression using the usual GLM function
and the question we will ask ourselves
in this particular top is can we trust
the inference that we commonly see in
standard software packages in a modern
high dimensional regime I'll soon
specify what that means but here
throughout this top then the sample size
is denoted by N and the number of
features is denoted by P so these are
dimensions with n is 200 P is 16 which
does not look high dimensional just
looking at it but we in quantified this
to be high dimensional as well and I'll
make that precise okay so this is the
goal we want to evaluate the standard
errors the P values that we get here are
they accurate in high dimensional
settings ok so let me just briefly
introduce the notations there are the
usual usual notation so we have n iid
samples of with labels which are binary
in this case and the distribution of the
labels given the covariance is modeled
using the usual sigmoid function so beta
is the unknown vector of regression
coefficients here and you know what the
maximum likelihood estimate is for this
model along with the maximum likelihood
estimate another statistic we are very
familiar with is the log likelihood
ratio statistic which can be used for
testing whether a particular coefficient
is significant or not and throughout
this stop the reduced ml eats so the
reduced emily's for a particular
predictor is basically we can drop that
predictor and
compute the MLE again and we call that
the reduced Emily that's a usual
terminology okay and we all know these
results so this is the first one is the
classical maximum likely distribution
these are under be fixed and sample size
diverging so we know that the Emily is
approximately centered around the true
regression vector after this centering
and appropriate scaling in the limit
this is asymptotic normal and we know
the variance is given by the inverse
Fisher information and what we also know
is the celebrated works theorem which
tells us that in the limit of classical
asymptotics negative twice log
likelihood ratio statistic converges to
a chi-square so this case this is true
for our testing a single coefficient or
groups of coefficients under the
appropriate null hypothesis and
subsequently there have been extensions
of these sorts of results for parametric
families in works of Hooper and 49 and
these consider diverging dimensions but
the dimensions they consider go at most
to the regime P equals model or square
root n okay and we know that roughly up
to this threshold the results continue
to hold for a lot of parametric families
okay so as I told you at the beginning
of this table what we are learning
examine is is classical inference
accurate in modern settings where N and
P are both large and for instance the
ratio of n over P is 5 or 10 and both
are large and the high dimensional is
quantified simply in terms of the ratio
here okay okay so what do we see in
simulation studies let me first
introduce a particular setting in which
we are going to look at a few
simulations next so we'll consider
Gaussian covariance which are drawn from
which are which have iid entries and the
columns are scaled to have unit Noor and
the coefficients are chosen such that
the variance of the log odds ratio so
the log odds ratio in this model is
simply X I transpose beta so the
variance of the log odds ratio is held
fixed in all the simulations and one
reason why we suddenly hold this
quantity
because of this picture on the right so
here I'm showing you the sigmoid
function in red and superimposed in
black is the density of a normal with
mean zero and variance 5 so basically we
we our enemy will be doing high
dimensional simulations but we want to
restrict ourself to situations where the
distribution of the response the
probabilities of the response are
sampled roughly from the bulk of the
sigmoid simply so that we don't have a
degenerate distribution for the response
so basically we don't want ourselves to
be out in this extreme or that extreme
to have a meaningful problem ok so this
is a single run of a logistic regression
in R these are the dimensions and I'm
showing you the regression coefficient
vector in black and the Emily
coordinates are shown via the blue
points so what you see is the first
hundred coefficients are positive the
next hundred are negative and everything
else is zero this is for the true signal
and it turns out that the Emily is
actually systematically overestimating
the effect magnitudes so for the
positive coefficients the Emily points
are primarily above for the negative one
sits primarily below and for the others
we see that this is roughly centered
around zero and this is not specific to
this particular simulation we can repeat
this under the same setting we can
repeat this changing the dimensionality
changing the combinations of N and P we
can even consider much smaller N and P
keeping the ratio the same will
basically see this picture again and
again so this is a different setting
where I'm showing you the scatter plot
of the maximum likelihood coordinates
versus the true signal and in black I'm
showing you the diagonal line so what we
see here is that the scatter plot is
does not seem to be centered around the
black line instead it seems to be
centered around this red line which has
slope approximately point 1.5 so
basically what I'm trying to show you
here is it seems that even in moderately
large samples the maximum likelihood
estimate seems to be over biased
systematically at the n on the scale of
prediction this basically means that
predictions are biased towards extremes
and
maybe many of you have actually
encountered these kinds of observations
because it's kind of known that the
Emily predictions based on the Emily is
not good in high dimensions but we will
try to see why this actually happens
okay so what happens to the variance so
we have classical formally for computing
the synthetic standard deviations right
given by the Fisher information so in
this particular setting we can calculate
that and I am showing you that in the
black black in the blue dotted line on
the left and we can also ask you that
the variances using Monte Carlo
simulations so we restrict ourselves to
the null coefficients in this setting
and we estimate the where the standard
standard errors and histogram is shown
on the right and we see a clearer shift
of the cystogram to the right which
indicates that in high dimensional
settings the Emily exhibits a variance
inflation so it's clear from here that
the classical value in this case does
not seem to be accurate because the red
histogram is clearly not centered around
that particular value okay and finally
because we saw that huh even for now
coefficients the variance is not
accurate give L given by classical
formula so it's natural to wonder what
happens to the likelihood ratio
statistic and if we compute not the
values of the likely pressure statistic
based on the standard classical
chi-square approximation we see that the
p-values are actually far from uniform
and not just so the p-values have a huge
spike at zero which basically is
particularly problematic from a multiple
testing perspective so we are we are
doing really bad on the scale of small T
values and we care about these p-values
being very accurate
so now you might be wondering that all
of this is fine but classical
asymptotics are asymptotic results and
everything I'm showing you is finite
sample we're doing simulations right so
is this a finite sample effect and many
people have wondered about these kinds
of scenarios and small sample cases so
it is well known in the literature that
the MLE exhibits bias in small samples
it's well known that the Phi square
approximation to the log likelihood
ratio statistic performs poorly in small
samples and several correction methods
have been suggested there are two
parallel lines of work one line of work
basically tries to address the bias
problem in the Emilee and the other in
the LMR and the typical theme in these
works is the following so we can
complete so one can compute the
expectation of this log likelihood ratio
statistic by doing certain expansions
and we one can compute this up to some
order one over n terms and when I talk
of order in this particular statement
all the orders are calculated on their
classical assumption that P is fixed and
n is diverging okay so this order 1 over
N squared is assuming that P is fixed in
reality here there is a highly
mathematically intractable expression
and when P is diverging it's not clear
how to tackle what happens to the how to
tackle that expression and so what
people have studied are Corrections of
this form so one can scale the log
likelihood ratio statistic by 1 plus
alpha n over N where alpha n is a good
or accurate estimate of alpha so the
scale statistic will be closer to a
price quare on average ok now I'm going
to show you the results from Bartlett
correction which is a specific choice
for alpha n it has been quite popularly
used so if we obtain P values which have
been corrected using this Bartlett
correction these are now P values using
the Bartlett corrected scale statistic
so here we see that the spike at 0 has
significantly diminished but at the same
time this is
far from uniform and we have implemented
some of the bio finite sample bias
correction methods in the literature
also in high dimensional settings and we
see a similar feature that they
certainly improve over classical results
but they typically do not go all the way
to correcting the problems that I
alluded to earlier so hopefully I have
convinced you by now that what's going
on is not merely a finite sample effect
so just to go over the phenomena I
talked about the first one is that the
Emily over estimates effect magnitude
systematically the next is the
variability in high dimension seems to
be much larger than what has been known
classically and finally the distribution
of the LRT or the log LRT seems to be
far from a chi-square so hopefully I've
convinced you so far that there is some
need for different like maximum likely
theory if we are in a high dimensional
setting ok so let me introduce the Hydra
know the the setting that you have so we
are going to consider iid Gaussian
covariance as in the simulation settings
appropriately scaled and we'll consider
a sequence of problems where N and P are
both diverging but P over N goes to a
constant which is going to be positive
ok so we call that constant Kappa
throughout and we quantify the signal
strength is in this problem by the
variance of the log odds ratio and we
call the limit of that object to be
gamma squared and we assume that this
gamma square is finite so basically we
have a sequence of problems and in each
each instance and in P are both
increasing what we hold what we impose
is that this variance should not diverge
as n increases here are the random
variable insects I mean you can think of
everything is conditional on beta
and there are a few conditions on the
signal they're kind of mild conditions
all the assume is like the empirical
distribution of the coordinates of the
signal has some weak limit the limit
must have finite second moments and we
also assume convergence of the moments
so there is no sparsity assumption on
the signal in for these results okay so
even before we can go into this problem
further there is the first stumbling
block that is we know very well that
them Emily does not exist in this model
always and this has been characterized
geometrically my Albert in Anderson we
all know that if hyperplane perfectly
separates the cases from the controls
then the essentially you can find a
maximum likelihood estimate which will
have norm in finite so it doesn't make
sense to talk about these objects there
but for our purposes we need an
analytical characterization of when the
Emily exists and this dates back to some
of the early works of Tom cover so he
characterized that if the covariates are
drawn iid from a continuous distribution
and if there is no underlying signal so
the true regression vector is 0
throughout then Emily does not exist
asymptotically if Kappa is bigger than
half so T is bigger than n over 2 then
does not matter what distribution no the
covariates were drawn from if there is
no signal
the Emily will not exist so this is
agnostic to the distribution of the
covariance as long as it's a continuous
distribution
so we try to characterize the existence
of the Emily for Gaussian covariance and
here we can consider arbitrarily
correlated Gaussian covariance actually
and they show that there is a particular
curve in the Kappa gamma plane such that
beneath the curve the MLE exist so if
Kappa is below that curve for all such
points that MLE exists and above it does
not
and when I say Simpson does not exist
this means in an asymptotic sense when
PN are both diverging and P over N goes
to Kappa and in this word we also have
an explicit characterization of a
formula for this curve so this can be
precisely evaluated and calculated and
if we look at this curve essentially
this point on the right or which
corresponds to a PI equals 0.5 and gamma
equals zero is essentially coerce point
so for the rest of this stuff I will
restrict myself to the regime where the
Mme exists so all of our theory is gonna
hinge on an extremely crucial ingredient
so I'll spend some time in introducing
this ingredient so this is an equation
system we'll call it s in 3 on it and
the unknowns are gonna be alpha sigma
and lambda so I'm just keeping the
notation on the board for your reference
so there is an equation system s ok now
if we stare at the system let's forget
the thing on the left for the time being
so there is a bivariate random vector Q
1 and Q 2 which is jointly multivariate
normal and the covariance is a
particular form so in the covariance we
see that F and Sigma comes up so these
are two of the unknowns but other than
that Kappa and gamma also shows up and
what do we see on the left on the left
we see three equations sure and in each
of them we have an expectation which is
basically an expectation over Q 1 and Q
2
and within the expectations we have some
complicated functions it doesn't matter
the form of the functions but on the
left also if you parse it for some time
you will see that other than these three
unknowns the only two other parameters
are Kappa and gamma so any solution to
this system of equations will be a
function of these two objects so just to
remind you
gamma is gamma square is the signal
strength parameter Kappa is the
dimensionality and the row function you
see here is the usual link function in a
logistic model and equation equation
system crucially involves a proximal
mapping operator of the link function
okay so the main takeaway from here is I
have introduced the system of equations
such that any solution is a function of
Kappa and gamma okay but it's not clear
whether this system has a solution and
what can be shown is in the regime where
the MLE exists asymptotically this
equation system will have a unique
solution in that regime okay so
basically MLE exists in that regime
equation has a unique solution and I'm
going to call the solution corresponding
stars and the solution is function of
Kappa anthem
okay so now I have introduced the main
ingredient for the rest of our theory
the first result we have characterizes
the average behavior of the MLE
coordinates and what it says roughly is
the following
so a typical coordinate of the MLE is
actually centered around as four star
times beta J so beta is the regression
vector so beta J is the jet coefficient
of the regression vector okay so a
typical coordinate of the MLE is
centered around as four star times beta
j so it's there seems to be a
multiplicative factor here and after
this entering asymptotically the
variance is given by this quantity Sigma
star squared I feel embarrassed to ask
this displace and it's all cool if I
exists like I can always solve the
optimization problem
so by existence a terminology just says
that you have a finite solution financed
yeah yeah otherwise you can have
basically a solution whose normal being
payment thanks for the question I think
it was necessary to query ok so more
generally what we show is there is a
class of bivariate functions of nice
functions such that when we apply the
function with the first argument of the
function is the centered version of the
M&E okay and the second argument is the
jet coordinate of the signal so when we
apply this bivariate function to these
two vectors and we take averages this
converges almost surely to the subject
so what is this object on the right so
this is expectation of size I is the
same nice function but the first
argument is a Gaussian with mean zero
and variance is Sigma star squared and
the second argument is okay so beta
vector is the regression vector and beta
scalar is a realization from Phi where
Phi is the weak limit of the empirical
empirical distribution so basically what
it says if you just look at the first
argument is the interpretation of us
but roughly the Emily centered around
alpha star times beta and the variance
is given by this term and we'll see in a
bit what is the power of having the
second argument okay I mean for now you
could think of forgetting the second
argument and just focus on the first
argument which the representation is
written on the top okay so this result
immediately gives some interpretations
so the first one is the following we can
choose I of T to be T that tells you
that alpha star is the bias term so for
the picture on the Left we can solve the
system of equations and alpha star turns
out to be exactly the slope of the red
line that I showed you before and on the
right I'm showing you the the behavior
of alpha star is Kappa and gamma are
increasing so on the x axis Kappa is
increasing and I'm showing you different
values of different curves for different
values of gamma so from the right to the
left to left gamma square is increasing
and the same they say that the bias
increases as either of these parameters
increases which is not that surprising
because in in some sense the
dimensionality and the signature and
together you know encapsulate how much
we are deviating from classical sort of
data sets that we used to see okay and
so this is the variance term and if we
look at the ratio of this this standard
deviation with classical standard
deviation we see a similar behavior the
interesting thing in both the previous
case and here is when Kappa is zero it
seems to be recovering all the classical
values so this this ratio goes to one
man cap I call zero and we can choose
another function here for psy of tu or
using which we can construct confidence
intervals which will have a guaranteed
average coverage so this is for this
particular simulation that showed you
earlier so these are the average
coverages and we see that we are pretty
close to the target and the standard
errors are in the parentheses you could
be thinking that okay sure
but maybe the non null and the null
coordinates are balancing each other so
on
average we see a good behavior so we
want to be sure whether that's exactly
what's going on and so the power of
having this bivariate function is we can
plug in objects which are functions of
the signal itself so here we can we can
plug it in the indicator of U naught
equals zero and that gives us confidence
intervals for just the non null
coordinates and we once again have
average coverage guarantees for these
functions
another flavor of results that we have
are of this firm that if we look at any
null variable its marginal distribution
is asymptotically normal with this
variance and these are asymptotically
independent jointly and so this is just
an illustration to show you how this
weak limit performs and real in infinite
samples so we are looking at for any
null coordinate we are looking at the
scaled emileeh so it's beta hat J scaled
by the corresponding standard deviation
and then we apply the normal CDF to it
so after this this should be a uniform
and we see a perfect agreement with the
with the diagonal so this is empirical
CDF's of this object and this object
should be in uniform
and finally we have a card a
characterization of the asymptotic
distribution of the log like simply Shu
statistic and what we say is instead of
a chi-squared it is going to be a
multiple of a chi-square and a multiple
involves the dimensionality Kappa it
involves the variance parameter and this
is where you see the last component in
the solution coming in so we have had
interpretations of the first component
in terms of bias this one in terms of
the variance and the last one actually
comes up in the distribution of the LRT
so once again we see a similar behavior
for this rescaling constant it increases
as capurganá increases and these are
bulk asymptotics about behavior so it's
a histogram of 90 values on the left
using our correction and the
corresponding empirical CBS and we were
curious to see how it would perform in
the extreme tails and we see we have
perfect agreement with the uniform even
individuals which is reassuring from a
multiple testing perspective okay and
there are a few simulations which
basically shows you that although we
have the theoretical guarantees under
iid Gaussian setup this actually works
for non Gaussian covariates as well so
this is a particular choice motivated by
gmass applications where basically we
have data on snips and these typically
take values 0 1 & 2 and we know under
hardy-weinberg equilibrium these the
probabilities of these values will be
related by these forms so PJ is some
free parameter so we see the same
picture for the bias and then these are
all the other restrictions for all the
other results so for the tail behavior
recently we see a slight deviation but
we believe that this is happening
because for the sub Gaussian case the
synthetic squeaks in later so in finite
samples when you go far out in the tails
you would see that coming in so
okay so in the remaining few minutes I
will try to give a very brief on
high-level overview of our main
mathematical ideas so for the phase
transition of the Emily we have
primarily used ideas from high
dimensional stochastic geometry these
lead back to results of cover and many
other people have worked on this but
what we primarily borrowed from was the
paper living on the edge these
transitions in random convex problems
this is due time alums in at all the
average behavior of the Emily we borrow
heavily from the generalized approximate
message-passing literature which spans
the series of papers a ling a few other
papers later and also some literature
and robust and estimation how we use
tools called leave one out arguments
which are actually i kind of a variant
of the cavity method that so talked
about in his talk and these are also
deeply related to robust an estimation
literature where these arguments were
kind of introduced in and also some non
asymptotic random matrix theory ok so
let me make an attempt at trying to give
a very high-level overview of how
approximate message-passing probe
techniques work so we are interested in
the distribution of the MLE and in the
logistic model and in other GL ends this
does not have a closed form expression
not all GL ends because linear
regression is a special case of that so
this does not have a closed form
expression in general so the idea is
three stage the first stages introduce
an iterative algorithm such that the
algorithm when when we consider the
fixed points of the algorithm the
iterates actually satisfy the same
condition as the MLE so what do we know
about emily we know that the gradient of
the likelihood of the log likelihood at
the emily is equal zero so that's the
first order optimality conditions for
the emily so introduce it an iterative
algorithm so that at it's fixed point
the iterates satisfy the same optimality
conditions as the
does okay so that is the first stage now
the next stages okay we do not know what
the MLE is and we cannot track it
mathematically but we will try to
mathematically track the EMP iterates
instead okay and in the final stage we
will try to show that the a MPE turrets
converge to the MLE in an appropriate
sense so the idea is at a high level we
cannot track the M&E mathematically so
introduce your surrogate for the
surrogate we go through this algorithmic
route try to analyze the surrogate
mathematically and then connect your
surrogate to the MLE to transfer all the
information you got for the surrogate to
to your Emily family okay so the
iterative algorithm exclaim we are going
to consider has a specific form so these
algorithms are all carefully designed
choices and they can be derived using
heuristic arguments from statistical
physics a great place to learn about
that is one of the lecture notes written
by Andrea that's where I learned it from
because very helpful so what do we see
in this iterative scheme so we have two
iterates beta hat T and s T so the beta
hat T are gonna be surrogate for your
Emily so we are updating that in a
specific way and we have some extra
functions I of T lurking around there so
sine of T you can interpret it as a
scaled residual and if you look at this
form the scaling involves some extra
parameters lambda T so what are the
terms which depend on T here there is
beta hat DST these are the iterates okay
but there is also this extra parameter
so this is going to be a scalar and we
are not going to specify it right now
okay so it's going to be a free
parameter it's also evolving with T but
we are going to specify it later so you
have this iterative scheme now why this
scheme what you can do is the following
so we have the free parameter let's say
the free parameter is constant for the
time being and then if we just rewrite
the algo de it the algorithm
if we rewrite it at fixed points so if
beta had star an F star our fixed points
we can rewrite the algorithm and then
essentially if you look at the second
equation on the top then properties of
the props function immediately use this
relation this is a very crucial relation
so this says that X beta hat star is
essentially procs
of this object and using this relation
you can connect it back to the first
equation that gives you that beta hat
star satisfies this relation and in the
logistic model this is essentially the
first order optimality condition if you
take gradient of the Hessian this is
exactly the condition you'll get so
basically that says that at the fixed
point your iterative scheme the iterates
actually satisfy the same fixed point
conditions okay now I didn't introduce
the free parameter yet I'm going to kind
of gloss over the slide but basically
the free parameter lambda T should also
be chosen in a carefully designed way so
what we do is the following
so if we introduce a scalar system which
is also evolving over time so we had an
algorithm which was over evolving over
time what we will do is parallel we will
introduce a scalar system that is
evolving over time now the scalar system
will have three parameters and the
scalar system will be called a state
evolution sequence
so it has three parameters alpha of T
Sigma of T lambda of T so what you do is
the following we initialize alpha and
Sigma at some values and first we solve
the first equation lambda T is a
solution to that equation one can prove
that this equation will have a unique
solution and then you update alpha of T
and Sigma of T in a specific form then
you go back and update lambda of T and
so on so and you go on iterating this so
you're running a MP algorithm with
certain iterates each time you have to
pick a lambda T in parallel you will run
the scalar system where you're
iteratively updating lambda T and you
plug that in in the algorithm but the
nice thing is we don't have to worry
about this thing depending on T so in
the region where the MLE exists this
iterative scheme is going to converge to
a fixed point and you can check that
this fixed point is going to be the
solution to our system of equations so
essentially if I initialize this thing
at the solution it's not going to change
over T okay
so just keep that point in mind and this
is where the system of three equations
actually comes from okay so the next one
is tracking the iterates we our state
evolution sequence which is this scalar
parameter so this step is usually called
correctness of state evolution what that
says is roughly the following so we have
a state evolution sequence here I am
saying that let's initialize it in a
smart way so we are going to choose the
initial points to be the fixed point of
the fixed point so that this thing does
not change over time and then if the MP
iterates are initialized in a particular
way which is related to the initial
values of the state evolution sequence
then essentially the MP marginals will
have the same behavior so what we show
is a typical marginal so this this is
for fixed T and n going to infinity so
we show that for for any fixed e as the
sample size diverges a typical marginal
of your MP turrets is roughly centered
a star x beta j and in the limit this is
the this is the variance okay so I
haven't talked about what happens to the
Emily yet we show that the MP turrets
have this property but this is for fixed
T and n diverging okay so what does that
say it basically says that as the star
and Sigma star tracks the bias and
variance of the a MPE turrets and now we
come to the final stage that is now we
can basically if we can relate the a MPE
traits to the emelina in the correct way
you can kind of predict what's going to
happen next
essentially we show that you know if
this thing is initialized in a
particular way then the limits of the
the limits of the a MPE traits those
functions when we take T going to
infinity so the order is important here
so first we fix T and we take and go
into infinity the inside limit and then
if we take T going to infinity that
converges to the corresponding limiting
value for the MLE okay and so what this
says is all the information about large
sample bias and variance of the am PE
turrets can be transferred to the Emily
essentially by this Shrugged okay and
that gives us this is the biases
variance and there's a typical behavior
of the marginals so this was the high
level three stage route and there is
another proof technique that we use so
the other component is the log
likelihood ratio statistic and what we
know is it can be expressed as sum of
two to two quantities and there is
nothing high-dimensional going on here
and this is purely from like logistic
model this this is we all know from
classical statistics so the first term
is a quadratic term and the second term
is a cubic term in this expansion okay
and the thing is these two objects are
high dimensional and dependent so in the
classical case we knew their Joint
Distribution so we could track down what
happens to each of these terms now how
do we track these differences
so it's again a similar idea but
slightly different route so we replace
beta hat by a surrogate and the
surrogate we start from the reduced
Emily so starting from the radio stem le
we replace it by a surrogate it has a
particular form that's probably not that
important this was introduced in the
context of robust MSM estimation by Elle
Korean collaborators and for each
problem the surrogate will have a
carefully tailored choice and then we
show that beta hat is very close to the
surrogate the order is n to the minus
half there's some correction term but
the crucial thing is because we started
from the reduced emily using that
representation we can track the fitted
values and we can shown and supremum of
all these objects we can bar we can give
an upper bound on how large these
differences should be uniformly with
high probability
now next it's kind of like a few steps
so we have these these bounds on the
differences of the fitted values which
immediately tells us that the quadratic
term is negligible so the same thing
which goes on in classical statistics
this actually goes on here so the
quadratic term sorry the cubic term is
negligible we don't have to worry about
that the quadratic term we can simplify
further and in the simplification we are
crucially using the leave one out
representation because we had these
differences so we are crucially using
the leave one out representation and
then we have two terms the numerator is
the usual ghiyath coefficient like we
find in classical case and we show that
the scaling converges to a constant that
requires some random matrix results and
then using leave one out again we can
characterize the marginals and these
together basically gives you the
rescaling factor ok so just to wrap up
we introduced a system of equations with
the solutions and the solutions for
functions of Kappa and gamma and I
showed you that each of these components
in the solution has a specific
interpretation so the first term is the
bias the second term is the variance and
the variance and this last term together
characterizes the LRT distribution ok so
I'm out of time here I just want to say
that the signal strength is unknown
and we have a method to estimate that
which came out of discussions between
Emmanuel Rena and Boris and so we have
implemented that method and that seems
to be working quite well in practice so
here I'm showing you p-values based on
the estimates versus the truth or Atika
p-values and we see that these are in
perfect agreement so the estimation
procedure works quite well so that can
be used in practice okay so to wrap up I
talked about asymptotic normality or
family marginals of the LRT we looked at
V values obtained from this correction
some finite sample accuracy and I didn't
get time to go over estimation of the
unknown parameters this has several
operand deductions
we're currently currently working on a
distribution for penalized estimators
and of course they correlated covariance
is an open question and that's one of
the most interesting questions and this
generalizes to some other GLM's but I
cannot claim it does to all GMM so it is
of interest to see how a universe all
these results are yeah so okay I'll go
back to that part so actually you cannot
exchange the limit I was trying to say
that the the order of in which we take
the limit is very crucial for getting
the right characterization no no no this
is a result so basically here we are
showing that so in this slide before
what we did was if we fix T for any
given T in large sample limit we can
show that RHS is given by this form and
then the next stage is to show that if
we take limit T goes to infinity on the
left that object the limit in that
specific order will be the same as the
limit as n goes to infinity so the here
it's the MLE and there is the MP turret
so I don't know whether you can exchange
the limit and you'll have the same thing
but the order of the limit is important
yeah one of the other web has a forum
which is some kind of expectation of
calcium yeah exactly so my dad limit T
we already showed you in the back that
it's expectation of the Gaussian it's
certain variance and that's why so
basically with doubt so this is just
limit n going to infinity this is
already discussion that's that right
side is independent yeah I thought is
independent of T that's right but we can
only show that the left side after
taking T going to infinity that it
converges yeah you could in principle
try to also not do that but I don't know
whether that can be done yeah yeah so
there is a formula for that quantity on
the right yeah you couldn't principle of
any analysis using am
otherwise the enemy directly as an
optimization wait like I assume you did
something you thought about that's and
it didn't work yeah yeah I am I'm hoping
maybe andrew has more insights here but
yeah so just as an optimization problem
we thought about it and we couldn't
figure out how to track the marginals
because there is no closer to do it one
is the leave one out yeah so you could
do it by via the leave one out rather
than doing the whole comparison sure yes
it is equivalent to yeah since most of
the work that they do is it's not in the
strategies really technically control
yeah yeah so there are some different
strategies you could use any of them I
guess I'm gone comparison you could also
use but I mean I guess they are
equivalent in terms of things but not
okay so I guess my answer was more like
we didn't come up with any new technique
which you know are not one of these
basically so what they're just about the
I want the shortest proof this is my
interest I really wish we would have
that someday but the moment not yet
genius
okay yep so for estimating gamma could
you think the iterative in an iterative
fashion you start somewhere you apply
your technique you get an estimate of
beta then you get your gamma and you
iterate so that sorry can you say the
beginning part of your question you
don't know what the gamma rays yeah yep
so you could start somewhere right and
unbiased estimate if that would be the
true gamma and then you eat through I
see you're saying that the decidua tip
scheme would converge to the to the true
gamma and be an estimate that could work
we can try that and see how that could
work
okay five-minute break until the next
ugh let's think about you